اطلاق النار فوق روؤسنا اللي يقول اقعد ما
يقعدش يرفع راسه يطخ من فوقيه كان طخ كثيف
من فوق الناس انا فاطمه حلاوه نازحه من
الشمال نزحنا الى الجنوب وهينا انتم
شايفين كيف الوضع سيء الوضع في الخيام
مزري خصوصا في الجو هذا جو المطر جو
الشتاء الناس طول الليل تصرخ
وتعيط وتحت
المطر هذه حرب ما عمرنا شفناها في حياتنا
يعني حرب حرب شعواء استهدفت المدنيين كلهم
الاطفال كل الشهداء من الاطفال والمدنيين
والناس وضعها صعب جدا طلعت من بيتي على
الله يعزكم قرات الحمار وصلنا لعند مفترق
الكويت وطلعنا برض من مفترق الكويت لقاره
كمان لعن قالوا للدبابه الاولى نزلنا عند
الدبابه الاولى كان الوفات من الناس وفات
من الناس وكان الوضع صعب جدا كانت الارض
طينه وميه والناس مش قادر الواحد يقف يرفع
ظهره والجيش اقف اقعد اقف اقعد والناس
بتغوص في الميه وفي اللاصفي
الوساخه قعدنا حوالي من الساعه 10 او من
الساعه 9عه الصبح للساعه عه على الحاجز
دخلنا الجيش قبالنا ارفع ايدك هويتك على
وجهك على الكاميرا اللي بدهم اياه ياخذوه
يصفوا الشباب ياخذو اللي ياخذوه معاه اللي
يرموه على الارض اللي كلنا اطفال كل الناس
معها اطفال واطفال تصوت وتسرخ الاطفال
كلهم بدهم بدهم علاج نفسي كل الاطفال
والله حتى الكبار بدها علاج نفسي من بعد
هالحرب اللي بضل طيب للحرب كله بده علاج
نفسي الصغار هيهم اللي حقيت في الليل
بيقوموا يصرخوا ويصوتوا من الخوف كلهم
خايفين والله بتمنى تقف هالحرب وترجع
هالناس لدورها حتى لو عملت خيام عند بيت
هالناس اف ما تضلها يعني مهجره في بلاد
الناس